[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it only took 10 years to bring the world
to the brink of collapse
this was a time where rising sea levels
collapsing economies
and broken alliances would transform
earth as we know it
in october 2033 the first ever category
6 hurricane occurred
hurricane sita and only a few months
later
in january 2034 the wide-scale fuel and
food shortages across the globe
led to a second great depression finally
in 2035 the european union officially
disbanded following germany's collapse
the world had become a hostile
environment everyone was out for
themselves
and a lot of previous alliances were
dissolved
a number of those who were left behind
needed to band together
in search of a safe place to exist
these people farmers doctors engineers
soldiers and a number of families who
had previously been worlds apart
were forced to join together in order to
survive
the media began to call them the
non-patrioted
they called themselves the no pets
by 2037 humanity had eventually begun to
adapt to this new way of life
and a number of revolutions in energy
desert irrigation
hydraulic levees and sea walls had
successfully reclaimed a lot of the
farmland previously lost
which enabled the rebuilding of supply
chains and this progress led to some of
the nations reopening their borders
however with no way of returning the 1.2
billion people back to their countries
of origin
the notepads became a permanent fixture
in all of the economic
military and social policy making
decisions
many of the notepads were still highly
distrustful of the governments that had
exiled them
and thus refused the invitation to
absorb themselves back into society
a number of no pet leaders emerged
inspiring a new identity
free from former nationality ties and
successfully draw a line in the sand
highlighting the difference between the
old world and the new world norms
we are no pets became a rallying cry
in 2040 a space storm knocked out over
70
of the world's satellites the subsequent
blackouts
caused mass devastation
planes crashed communications collapsed
and the global supply chains
once again came to a standstill as a
further result
the prices of grain oil and coal soared
thousands of lives were lost
with no internet no navigation no
surveillance
and no weather foresight the world has
lost some of its greatest tools in
communication
unsurprisingly geopolitical distrust
surged overnight
with no one able to spy on one another
they could also no longer
trust one another both russia and the us
came to a head
claiming the other was responsible for
the blackout while some suspected the no
pets were behind it
and accused them of trying to sow
anarchy
former military and combat trained
specialists among the nopats
rose up within the armed task forces in
a strategic move to defend themselves
as tensions continued to rise
it appeared that an all-out world war
was imminent
[Music]
with no other choice the no pets had to
choose sides
they were no longer fighting for a flag
but for their future survival
as expected the food and fuel shortages
only further ignited tensions
and a shadow war began where the
influences of russia and the united
states
helped to ignite the conflict between
other countries although they themselves
did very little fighting
to maintain plausible deniability both
sides fielded no pet task forces
as proxies and escalating conflicts over
resources
with the promise of giving them a piece
of what's left
the war between russia and the us fought
with no pet specialists and soldiers
took place across the globe
where both sides tried to maintain
control over vital resources
across a fractured earth
in battlefield 2042 the story narrative
will continue to be fed through the
battle pass seasons
and they'll be unique to those specific
time periods where the players are
present
additional law will also be found on the
maps as well as backstories for the
various characters
who all have their own origins that
align with the story
after collecting several parts of the
story things will slowly start coming
together
allowing you to understand the world and
the history of battlefield 2042
as already stated these battles will be
taking place all over the world
some of the locations that have been
revealed so far are
guyana where a battle takes place around
the site of an imminent rocket launch
[Music]
doha qatar a city that has been lost to
massive dust and sandstorms
brani island singapore tropical
tornadoes are a constant threat around
this vital american trade location
songdo south korea in this huge
metropolis
the fighting will occur between
skyscrapers and throughout the city
plazas
ylang india along a strategic section of
india's west coast
colossal ships stranded on the beach are
being stripped for parts
queen maudland antarctica oil extraction
has turned the freezing area into a
strategic hotspot
in the eastern desert of egypt through
the extreme conditions
a giant wall has been built to secure
rich man-made agricultural
areas
battlefield 2042 is set in a near future
fictitious yet real-world what-if
scenario
where the world is battling for survival
over the remaining resources
the remaining world superpowers are
utilizing soldiers who no longer have a
place they call home
to do their fighting for them with the
promise of something better if they were
to survive
i've spent a lot of time in battlefield
games over the years if by chance people
are interested in my slightly unorthodox
way of covering the game
awesome but either way i'll be playing
it regardless
anyway thank you very much for watching
and i'll catch you in the next one
cheers
attention all squads the russian troops
are falling back
[Applause]
we push them back but not far enough do
not let them regroup
you